when you start thinking about the growth
of this hash rate how much of this is
inside the united states versus
internationally and how important is it
that it's happening in the u.s to any
degree
i mean look
since the chinese ban and now with
what's going on in russia i think more
and more of this hatchery is going to
come online in north america there are
certainly feasibility studies and
planned projects that are looking at
south america and parts of northern
europe specifically norway and sweden
but it's likely that we're going to see
the vast majority of hash rate for the
remainder of this year come on in the
states
got it i should say in the states in
canada correct and the united states now
has what it's like 30 35 of global hash
rate with about 10 being in texas is
that like general ballpark
uh that's the ballpark i think you're
we're probably going to see close to 50
percent of the hatch rate in uh in the
united states here by the end of the
year how
big of an issue is it that more than 50
was in china and now if more than 50 is
in the u.s like is there still the same
quote-unquote strategic risk in terms of
the lack of decentralization to uh to
the network or do people not worry as
much because of the belief that the the
us is less uh authoritarian
you know bitcoin is non-state money so i
think that 50 more than 50 of the hatch
rate in any one country's borders poses
a risk to bitcoin uh but we're going to
see how bitcoin is respond i mean when
it was in china everyone was up in arms
talking about how we can't have that
much hatch rate in china but when we
have that much hatch rate domestically
we're going to see how people will
respond now fortunately the
conversations that we've had in
washington and in some of the states um
legislators are really keen to get
educated they're not looking to over
regulate it or so it would seem at this
point so i think that what we'll see is
a favorable or you know do no harm
uh
oversight over the next couple of years
out of washington and of course biden
just signed his executive order today
which you know i think all he really did
was call the the other agencies to arms
and say hey look we got to take a closer
look at things so i think we're in a
pretty good spot
what was your read on this executive
order it felt like it was more directive
hey go do a bunch of research come back
to me with reports but uh positive
negative
what's kind of your take
i think it was a bit of a nothing burger
you know
it's uh effectively it's the ceo of a
company saying hey look r d let's go out
and see what we have here
and i think that's good you know there
needs to be a lot more research into the
space before there are regulations that
come out that could potentially for
innovation so i think it was a smart
move this executive order we'll see what
comes from it but i think ultimately
what's gonna end up happening is you're
gonna have you know like the epa was
passed with looking into
uh into the space and i'm sure that's
going to come down heavily on mining but
what i feel they're going to find is
that you know bitcoin miners are
actually operating in a much more
efficient way and using much more clean
energy air quotes clean
um than has been purported in the press
to this point so i think it's gonna end
up being a big win for uh for bitcoin
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time